Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
I want to start with a verse
that many of us, most of us even, are
probably familiar with.
This verse, many of us are acquainted
with it or at least acquainted with its
meaning.
And it is perhaps one of the greatest
honors
and one of the greatest virtues
that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions in
the Quran for the scholars amongst his
creation.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala that which
translates to
it is only
those who are knowledgeable who are most
knowledgeable that fear Allah. Now
notice the wording here.
forch.
[Silence]
Subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala it is only
the very knowledgeable
from amongst his slaves who fear Allah.
And the word when we translate this
there is so much that is lost
when you look at translating Arabic and
I'm not speaking about modern Arabic
unfortunately a lot of
what plagues modern Arabic today and I'm
sure other languages as well is that it
is now becoming a follower to
English. So you'll see that a lot of
idioms, a lot of
a lot of sentence structures and so
forth are taken from English and
translated back into Arabic and then
used. And this is natural the natural
course of language that the languages of
the weaker
always try to emulate the languages of
the more powerful of the time. And so we
thank Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala so much
for the scholars of Islam who have who
have protected the Arabic language.
If it weren't for Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala preserving the Arabic language
through the scholars of Islam, it would
spell disaster
for the Muslims, for humanity
because we would no longer be able to
understand the Quran.
In this verse here, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us and as I was mentioning
before, when you when you try to
translate Arabic, especially something
the Quran into English or any other
language for that matter, but I'm
bilingual. English is is the only other
language I know. It's taking It's
taking a funnel, you know? You take
a funnel, you put it in the bottle to
pour liquids into another bottle. It's
taking that funnel and flipping it
upside down and then trying to pour the
liquid in it. Most of it is going to
what? Is going to leak out. You're
losing most of it. You're only getting
bare bones. You're only getting drops of
what was originally there.
And some of the scholars of Islam,
not one or two but in the dozens have
written up to an entire thick volume
just on explaining this verse and its
implications and what it includes and
what it articulates.
Islam
has a huge
respectable portion that is dedicated
only to this fatwa only to this verse
in his fatal.
The point here is that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala is telling us that it is only
the knowledgeable who fear Allah as he
is rightfully feared. And he used the
word
because in the Arabic language is
different than just fear. Fear and
they have a a base meaning that is the
same
and they mean the same thing at base
level. But there are implications of the
word
and so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
articulating in this verse that it is
only the most knowledgeable
only the most the the ones who exalt
Allah the most. It is only those who are
most knowledgeable with regards to the
revelations of Allah who are the ones
that have in their hearts the true
meaning and embody fear of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is a great
honor for the scholars. And that is why
the scholars of Islam
and when I say scholars of Islam, we're
speaking about those who learn and
implement
and those who are scholars in the words
of Allah and the words of the messenger
of Allah sallall.aii
And the implications of those words
that these scholars
they are gathered on the day of judgment
by themselves. They have an elite
gathering that is just for them that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gathers them.
These are men and some women. But it is
mostly the dominion of men historically
that reach the level of peak
scholarship.
These men and women
they are individuals that may not have
been with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam physically.
They didn't meet him.
Maybe they didn't even see him in a
dream. They had no contact with him.
They may come from lands that are
thousands of miles away, but these are
men who lived every day of their lives
and were with the messenger of Allah
with every breath he took. Sallai wasam.
Men that spent their youth and elder
years hunched over books and on their
knees at the feet of other scholars in
order to inherit from the messenger of
Allah sallall.aii wasallam. This is
extremely important. Why? The prophet
sallallah.aii Wasam tells us in Bkari
Muslim,
one of the great scholars of the
companions, he narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam said
[Silence]
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said whomever Allah wishes good for he
will grant him understanding
of the religion of the religion of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
,
[Silence]
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said whomever Allah desires good for
then he will grant him and teach him
understanding of his religion.
Now if we were to take the opposite of
that statement
meaning if Allah does not desire good
for someone he will not grant him
understanding of his religion. He will
keep him in the dark. He will keep him
ignorance. He will not allow him to come
close to understanding
and learning the names and attributes of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and what
follows.
[Silence]
Whomever Allah desires good for, he will
grant him understanding of the religion.
Meaning a people or an individual.
If Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala wishes a
good for a community or a people or a
country or a nation, he will place
amongst them scholars of Islam who will
teach him
als
men who will teach him because they are
the heirs of the prophets and
messengers.
In the previous nations, there was
always a prophet that would come to the
people and he would preserve and
continue the legacy of the messengers
before them. The prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam said
he said
they
were always in the presence or in the
midst of prophets.
Every time a prophet would pass away,
another would be appointed from amongst
them to take his place. a prophet in
order to preserve the message of Islam
to continue to teach it to propagate it
to carry on the legacy of Musam
the legacy of
even
these were examples of prophets they
would take the place they would they
would continue the legacy of the
messenger
now in this there's no more prophets.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
continues in this narration. He says,
[Silence]
He said,
"And as for me, there is no prophet ever
that will be after me, appointed as a
new prophet after me." He said, "And the
prophets do not leave behind inheritance
of gold or silver. Rather, their
inheritance is knowledge. And so whoever
takes and embodies and carries that
knowledge has taken and embodied and
carried a great a very great and grand
and illustrious and grave inheritance.
So what do we understand from this? We
understand that in this one of the
great virtues and merits of the of
[Arabic recitation]
which is specific to this umah
is that the scholars of Islam
have been commissioned with what the
prophets were commissioned with in
previous nations. They're not prophets
but they are filling that position that
a prophet would have in the previous
nations.
And so because of this,
if a person wishes to see where the
ummah is
generally and specifically in pockets
here and there or generally on an
international scale, you want to see
where are where are people where is the
ummah at you want to take the ummah's
pulse.
What do you look for? You look for the
scholars.
How numerous are there? are they? How
common place are they? How knowledgeable
are they?
How connected are they?
And because of this when a place or a
people or the entire ummah for that
matter has the death of scholars is
frequent and those who come up to take
those scholars place are fewer and fewer
every generation.
This these are footsteps that are being
taken off of the path of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala because the only thing that
keeps this umah on the path of Allah
is the Quran and Sunnah and we only have
access to the Quran and Sunnah but by
and through the scholars of Islam. The
that's the only way we have access to
the Quran and Sunnah.
And so and we will end with this. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
[Silence]
So,
he says su alaihi wasallam. Allah does
not take back knowledge by extracting it
from the hearts of men who have earned
it. Rather, he takes back knowledge from
a people by way of the death of the
scholars.
And this death of the scholars becomes
more and more frequent amongst a people
or in a place or amongst the ummah in
general until there's no more scholars
left in that place or amongst those
people.
And those people will then take for
themselves ignorant leaders. These
ignorant leaders, what do they look
like? We have to imagine them. What do
they look like? They they look like
scholars.
They talk the same. They wear the same
kind of clothes. They have really really
tall hats and fancy fancy you know
all the get up and all the uniform of
scholarship and they use a few buzzwords
that are used amongst the scholars but
they are ignorant. They have taken
scholarship as what? as a trade. You
know, they have degrees
where they go and get this achievement
or this degree and now they start to
give fatawa and teach and lead people
and make decisions that if those
decisions were left to Omar,
he would have gathered the muajir and to
take their opinion before saying
anything.
And so these ignorant leaders will then
be asked. They will then give fatwa
without knowledge and they will hence go
astray and take people astray with them.
This is where innovation comes from. And
so to close,
what does it mean to be ignorant? What's
the difference? If they look the same,
what's the difference? The answer is one
speaks with innovation and the other
speaks with Quran and Sunnah. One does
not take from the major scholars of
Islam and keep that lineage continuous
and one has a lineage that goes all the
way back to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. I'm speaking about a lineage
of knowledge.
I'm not speaking about a lineage of
bloodline, a lineage of knowledge.
Meaning that this person, everything he
says can be traced back to the major
scholars of Islam through 1,500 years of
knowledge. Everything,
no opinions, because opinions are the
opposite of the revelations of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. We ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he teach us of his book that he
raise us that he make our hearts a pure
place that he fills with his revelation
and give us the honor of being able to
be the ones that pass this revelation on
to the next generation. I think are you
also packed?
This is Abu J. This is Abdman. Abu
[Arabic recitation]
when there where there are less scholars
than previous generations? The answer is
yes. And the scholars that are around
whilst they are very high in caliber
they are nowhere near the caliber of
previous scholars.
Scholarship has clearly gone down
in the past 230 years. We could we could
even ask Abu Abdahman
when was the last agreed upon of Islam.
Huh.
So the closest
of that are left amongst us, the last
the last true
of scholars, the last true hath
that is agreed upon amongst the
scholarship of Islam that is a the last
one was around a
some scholars say. Do you know when a
passed away? Year 911.
How many years ago was that? 500 years.
And others mention a shani which is a
very strong opinion. A shani was about
200 years ago. And so we see that not
only are scholars less less common and
so rare in our time but they are as well
what they are as well not of the caliber
that the previous scholars of Islam
were. And there's a lot of reasons for
this. Now this isn't mean that our
scholars are of low caliber. Our major
scholars are of very high caliber.
However, they are few and far between
and they pale in comparison to previous
generations of scholars. You go back to
the time of Iben Kaf which was which was
about 700 years ago. How many hu were
there in the there were tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands.
And now the last known agreed upon. What
is a h? We say h say h meaning he
memorized the Quran that that wasn't
that wasn't uncommon you know kir where
he took his ria for a susi from his
chain of narration in one recitation isi
took it from his mother-in-law
his mother-in-law
he took his eza from his mother-in-law
can you imagine your mother-in-law right
now and taking an e jazza from
This is how common knowledge was in his
timeb
in his time
were in the tens if not hundreds of
thousands. What was a the in the in
Islam
is a person who has memorized committed
to memory verbatim at least 100,000
narrations at least. And when you reach
the threshold of 100,000 narrations,
you're considered a beginner hath
a beginner.
We say 100,000 narrations, we're
speaking about the chains of narration.
And so this is the lower end of the
threshold of the spectrum of
the last known half of the greed upon
was and some say a from Yemen who passed
away in the 13th century. The point here
is that knowledge has become a lot more
scarce and this is all as the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam prophesized. This
is not something that should be shocking
or no. This is all as he prophesized.
Why? The fitna
is only going to be in a time of extreme
widespread ignorance.
And I want you to make a difference in
your mind between a scholar, between
knowledge and information. Information
is everywhere, right? And we're all
literate, but knowledge so rare.
[Silence]
Subhanah.
And when will we return to that day of
might and is when we start to look at
our children, choose the best most
knowledgeable amongst him and say you
you are my favorite. You belong to Allah
and you send that child to be with the
scholars for 2030 years. And we do that
out of every household as the Muslims
used to. And what do we have? We have an
thriving with scholarship.
[Silence]
You look you want to say something.